we talked about this digital madness
that we live in all the time we never
stop looking at our phones the second i
shut off my phone i go to my ipad the
second i shut that thing i opened up my
computer and then watching screen on TV
and all that uh but facebook has now
come out with Simon season going take us
deeper into this rabbit hole uh they are
announcing that you can have a legacy
contact to control your Facebook page
after you die that's right so basically
it remembering April Myers so this is
what April Myers page look like before
she died and then someone else can take
control of it uh so there's a lot of
interesting things i think this brings
up and then here you see uh so you'll be
able to pick somebody to do it they can
either respond to people they can post
things they can update your profile
picture let me said etcetera etcetera
we've got we've got some info real quick
i'll get the legacy contact can download
an archive of the person's photos posts
in private information but will not be
able to see their private messages that
was profile information uh legacy
contacts still can't delete embarrassing
photos edit post that the deceased wrote
or delete the account entirely this is
because being able to curate the
person's page might add an extra
emotional load to grieving so real quick
i had a friend a good friend uh younger
than me who died out of nowhere in a car
accident and over the course of a couple
days after he died that that was one of
the major things that everybody was
talking about how to get his password
for his facebook page even just to let
people know that he died then who is
going to manage it all this so this
there is some need for this as kinda
creepy as it sounds i guess yeah I mean
I guess I doesn't seem like a real thing
I mean it seems like a real thing people
could do it doesn't seem like I think
facebook needs to get involved in I
guess though having of you know it's
like an emergency contact but it's a
gusher they're the biggest ever the
biggest emergency there is uh that
graphic you had before the last one that
just made me think of my dad who died in
but like it reminded me my dad died in
October but one thing that he was
insistent about he didn't we didn't know
it was dying but he was uh uh he hated
the term pass away nobody passes away
you die you'd like out let's not your
debt yeah I us to that little sort of
nuance of life
which was a we should probably avoid but
I mean I guess it's good yes people seem
to be doing anyway you see a lot of you
know what somebody famous dies and you
check there and I'll read they were on
Twitter just the day before and I'll
check their Twitter account and still
there yeah uh I guess this is something
that Twitter would be different I
suppose but you could Twitter may want
to do that as well right so I know that
uh Melissa rivers for example didn't
have Joan Rivers password so for months
they couldn't get in I don't know what
happened that Twitter wasn't helping
them then somehow they finally got in
now she's kind of promoting her own
stuff which seems a little exactly how
they lived I suppose yeah i mean they
lived publicly and you know you get they
ever gets to make their own the every
family gets to make their own decision
and you know I don't know Joan Rivers
personally but don't you suspect the
Joan read Melissa you can promote your
own stuff from my Twitter page after I'm
gone right go-go girlie the greatest
honor of her legacy Jimmy what do you
make this thing I just want to know what
happened to April why did she die she
she was so young [ __ ] such a whole life
ahead of I don't like jokes are you
looking at that you should be worrying
about what facebook if you could appoint
a legacy contact for when your career
dies oh very good we should actually
stop the recording and do that right now
I'll get Arsenio Hall's guy so the
perverse part of this does seem to me
that we can't stop with all this
technology stuff right we keep talking
about it we know people are spying on us
all this other stuff yet now we're even
worried about after death what does that
say about human like we never want to
let go of what we got here huh yeah I
couldn't give a [ __ ] of what happened my
facebook page after I die yeah yeah you
just don't care just could not care less
I don't think I'm gonna care about
anything when I'm dead but what about do
you want the jimmy dore fans at for you
i don't give a [ __ ] you i'm dead yeah I
don't give it what my fans do my leg
it's all [ __ ] that's all eagle while
you're alive when you're dead you don't
have a ego anymore you just have a soul
so you don't give a [ __ ] yeah all right
there we go jimmy dore believes in Souls
I can't believe it what do you think are
you gonna have a legacy contact when
you're dead and you're you want to keep
your Facebook page going let us know in
the comments right now